les touristes vont t'ils d'exercer
montmartre c'est en tout cas ce que
craignent les commerçants et les
chauffeurs d'autocars de la butte depuis
qu'on leur a annoncé des nouvelles
règles de circulation à partir du 4
novembre
lundi donc les autocars ne pourront plus
stationner sur la butte pendant la
journée et ne pourront plus circuler la
nuit satisfaction côté riverains colère
par contre côté chauffeur clément weill
raynal petite guerre au sommet de la
butte entre ceux qui vivent de
montmartre et ceux qui vivent à moment
l'enjeu de la bataille les autocars deux
chiffres pour comprendre 25 places de
stationnement autocar en haut de la
butte mais plus de 250 des mêmes autocar
qui chaque jour en période estivale
monte au sacré coeur
d'où la décision de la mairie
d'interdire le stationnement des
autocars de 9 heures du matin à 9 heures
du soir à partir de lundi prochain et à
titre expérimental pendant la visite des
touristes les autocars devront
redescendre stationnés boulevard de
rochechouart à charge pour les touristes
parlant français ou pas de redescendre à
pied en bus ou en funiculaire colère des
professionnels qui font valoir le
soutien de leur clientèle mais ce serait
vraiment dommage que cette chose soit
supprimé bon je viendrais plus si
l'écart était supplémentaire jusqu'au 5
mai colère des riverains pour qui la
simple interdiction de stationner
n'évite pas la pagaille occasionnés par
la montée des autocars une nouvelle
décision doit être prise
l'interdiction totale sollicité par une
enquête très sérieuse de la part la
municipalité et qui est vivement
encouragée par la case ih la totalité
l'unanimité des montmartrois et des
amoureux de montmartre les tours
opérators soutenu par les commerçants
voudrait une autorisation de stationner
de 20 minutes la profession s'organisera
distille non rétorque que la mairie et
les spécialistes impossible d'organiser
une visite de groupe dans ce laps de
temps c'est rochechouart ou rien plus
personne ne viendra nous amenions 60 %
de leur chiffre d'affaires aux
commerçants rétorquent les
professionnels qui n'entendent pas
baisser les bras
alors s'il n'y a pas de solution
satisfaisante pour vous lundi matin
qu'est ce qui se passe lundi matin
écoutez à ce propos nous verrons ce que
sont les intentions de la profession
prévoyez d'éventuelles actions
la profession on décidera